Discord has been hit by several hacking
attacks recently its encryption isn't
secured enough and it's open to all
making it a playing field for the
hackers they can use phishing attacks
where messages often appear to be from
trusted sources but it's important to
verify any requests for personal
information for example one such attack
targeted Gamers by offering them free
games in exchange for logging into a
fake website other common attacks are
Trojans once downloaded they can give
attackers remote access to compromised
systems and steal sensitive information
the malware like Anarchy Grabber 3 is
distributed through fake plugins or
modified Discord clients that uses
unwittingly download and use another
Trojan named Nitro hack spreads through
phishing emails and will take control of
users accounts so remember regularly
update your antivirus use two-factor
authentication never click on suspicious
links and make sure you don't link a
bank card to your account use a virtual
one instead stay safe on Discord